Новобудови у Братиславі.
Саме в цьому мікрорайоні живе прем’єр країни Роберт Фіцо.
Журналістка Зузана Петкова брала участь в
розслідуванні махінацій, пов’язаних з будівництвом.
Петкова з’ясувала, що уряд Фіцо прикривав
махінації будівельної компанії
Ідеться про багатомільйонні суми.
Вони просто швиденько змінили закон, який
дозволив будівельній компанії оплатити ПДВ заднім
числом і залишитися непокараною.
Вона так і вчинила.
І це лише один з багатьох випадків, які доводять,
що корупція сягає самої верхівки.
Це настільки постійне явище, що суспільство вже звикло.
Петкова постійно нервово озирається.
Цю справу, як і інші, вона розслідувала зі
своїм колегою Яном Куціяком.
У лютому його вбили.
Журналістка розпитує людей, які живуть поруч з новобудовою.
Як видавався дозвіл на будівництво?
Запит на дозвіл подали заднім числом і потім його таки видали.
Це неправильно.
Але це не єдина проблема чинного уряду.
У таких випадках здіймається коротка хвиля
обурення, а потім все вщухає, як завжди.
Утім, багато що змінилося в Словаччині після вбивства Яна Куціяка.
Це він на журналістському семінарі минулого року.
Нещодавно десятки тисяч осіб вийшли на
демонстрацію проти уряду і зростання корупції
в країні і таки домоглися відставки Фіцо.
Зузана Петакова, виступаючи на акції протесту,
вимагала швидкого розслідування вбивства Яна та його нареченої.
Демонстранти не сумніваються, що уряд Фіцо
підтримував зв’язки з організованою злочинністю -
саме це розслідував убитий журналіст.
Я ще в 1989 році виходила на протести проти комуністів.
Нині потрібні нові зміни і правда має перемогти.
Головне, щоб люди в країні могли знову почуватися в безпеці.
У мене немає більше цього відчуття.
А от що дозволяв собі колишній прем’єр-міністр країни.
На цій прес-конференції він назвав журналістів "проститутками".
Зузану Петкову це не дивує.
Але вона боїться, що цькування з боку політиків
матиме наслідки для журналістів.
Після вбивства Яна ми в редакції змушені були
вдатися до певних заходів безпеки.
У групах розслідувань, наприклад, ми користуємося
лише зашифрованими каналами передачі даних.
Ми більше не листуємося електронною поштою,
ми зустрічаємося в надійному місці
і там обмінюємося інформацією.
Кілька тижнів тому автомобіль Петкової
загорівся під час руху.
На щастя, вона змогла швидко загальмувати.
Спочатку вона подумала, що це технічна несправність.
Аж поки не зустрілася в торговому центрі з одним інформантом.
Неочікувано йому зателефонували з гаража
і сказали, що його автівка загорілася.
Ми разом прибігли туди, і я побачила, що його автомобіль
горить точнісінько, як мій.
Відтоді я про нього нічого не чула.
Тоді я не задумувалася про це і не звернулася в поліцію.
Але зараз думаю, може, мене хотіли так попередити?
Попри це Петкова продовжує свої розслідування.
Вона вважає це справою честі по відношенню
до Яна Куціяка та його нареченої.
Сили їй додають заходи, присвячені пам’яті вбитих,
та підтримка громадськості у Словаччині.
Сподіваюся, що після цього вбивства
нарешті щось зміниться.
У нас, у словаків вкрали нашу державу,
інститути влади корумповані і ні на що не здатні.
Тому і сталася така трагедія.
Ми не думали, що в 2018 році таке можливо.
Принаймні не в країні, яка належить до Євросоюзу.
На думку Петкової, вбивство Яна Куціяка в серці
Європи - це не лише проблема Словаччини.